the nhs testing traces a government-run
service for the whole of the uk
and it's a crucial part of the country's
coronavirus strategy
it's divided into four pillars the main
pillars
are one and two which are nhs tests
and community lab tests and these make
up the bulk of
tests in the uk here
is the official graph used to show the
number of tests
versus the capacity that is available
the gray line here shows the capacity
available in labs from pillar one and
pillar two
the bars and the yellow line here
show the total and average number of
tests processed
now according to the government's chart
capacity
is outstripping the number of tests but
if you examine the data in detail things
look very different
look closely at the pillar to data
here on the 23rd of august you can see
that capacity was breached
that's more people needing a test than
the system
can cope with earlier i spoke to dr
duncan robertson
it's his analysis that found the problem
i asked him what impact this extra
demand on pillar one
could actually have what we're seeing in
the data is that
the number of uh tests in pillar one is
reaching about eighty over eighty
percent
so this means that uh you know a
significant amount of the capacity
within these nhs and public health
england labs is being taken up
and while pillar two is important for
people going to school and getting about
their general life
the real problem comes if you don't have
the capacity
to test patients in the nhs patients and
doctors
so we know that the government's test
and trace system has been overrun but
that hasn't stopped
prime minister boris johnson from
repeatedly claiming
that the uk is carrying out more tests
than any other european country but
is this true well it depends on what
data
you're looking at the latest statistics
show that the uk is carrying out 2.55
tests
a day per thousand people
it is true this is higher than most
countries in europe there's only a few
countries doing more tests than this
like denmark which is doing 6.21 tests
per thousand according to this data
germany
is doing 1.8 tests per thousand it's
crucial to remember though
that the number of tests does not refer
to the same thing
in each country there is no rule as to
what countries need to report whether
it's
number of tests or number of people
tested in fact
in germany they don't even collect data
for the entire country
only by region so the pms claim that we
are doing more
testing than most of europe may not
be entirely true